Frau Wagenknecht welche Auftritt hat ihn
heute eigentlich besser gefallen der
Besuch von beiden in Kiew und auch in
Polen oder die Rede von Putin weder noch
also Putins Rede war eine Kriegsrede ist
klar und was mich wirklich was mir Angst
macht ist dass jetzt ja Russland auch
angekündigt hat aus dem saatvertrag
auszutreten nachdem schon vorher mehrere
große Abrüstungsverträge der einenf
Vertrag der ABM Vertrag der Open
sky-vertrag von den USA gekündigt wurden
das heißt wir gehen in eine Welt mit
immer weniger Vertragswerk wo immer mehr
hochgerüstet wird ich finde das
wahnsinnig gefährlich aber ich finde
auch die Signale die beiden auf seiner
Reise ausgesendet hat genauso gefährlich
weil er sagte und er geht nach wie vor
nur den militärischen Weg er will mehr
Waffen liefern es gibt keine
diplomatischen Anzeichen keine
diplomatische Initiative kein Angebot
und damit schaukelt sich das beidseitig
immer mehr hoch und ich finde das kann
sich diese Welt die volle Atomwaffen ist
nicht leisten die hätte den beiden auf
reagieren sollen sind interessant dass
sie bei beiden das kritisieren und bei
Putin nicht ich meine an welcher Stelle
in Putins Rede haben sie die Hand
gesehen die er uns reicht an welcher
Stelle hatten Sie das Gefühl das ist das
Wichtigste Rede ist nicht eine Rede wo
man eine Hand reicht aber es ist doch
unsere Verantwortung auch als westliche
Staatengemeinschaft alles dafür zu tun
diesen Krieg zu sein
einer die Hand für Verhandlungen um das
noch mal zu präzisieren das meinte ich
damit also ob natürlich ist er keine
Hand gereicht worden aber wenn wir auch
keine reichen im Krieg ist es ja so das
wird das Zeichen der Schwäche bedeutet
wenn einer der beiden Seiten jetzt sagt
er will verhandeln das heißt es geht
gerade jetzt darum dass Länder die nicht
direkt an diesem Krieg beteiligt sind
Friedensinitiativen Staaten und der
Westen ist zum Glück noch nicht direkte
Kriegspartei allerdings werden wir immer
tiefer in diesen Krieg hineingezogen und
deswegen ist es meine Sachen sind unsere
Aufgabe statt immer neue immer größere
Waffen anzukündigen jetzt über
kampfplätze zu nachdem die Panzer
geliefert werden endlich ein
Friedensangebot zu machen und dann
natürlich auch darauf zu drängen auch
mit Vermittlung Chinas und andere Länder
das ist Gespräche gibt und wenn Russland
diese Gespräche dann ablehnt dann kann
man meinetwegen über vieles andere reden
aber wir müssen es doch erst mal
versuchen bisher gibt es keinerlei
Friedensinitiative des Westens es gibt
Friedensinitiativen von Lula de
brasilianischen Präsidenten es gibt sie
vom Vatikan es gibt Bemühungen aus
verschiedenen Ecken mit verschiedenen
versucht ja weil es nicht geht solange
der Westen nicht mitmacht also es gibt
ja zum Beispiel die Aussage Westen
Entschuldigung na ja aber solange die
Natur nicht mitmacht und vor allem die
USA nicht mitmacht ich meine der
israelische der ehemalige israelische
Ministerpräsident hat ja im Frühjahr
versucht zu vermitteln und nach seiner
Aussage hat das jetzt in meinem
Interview sehr deutlich geschildert
hatte er auf beiden Seiten sowohl auf
der ukrainischen als auch auf der
russischen Seite eine relativ große
Kompromissbereitschaft und er sagt er
war davor ein Waffenstillstand zu
erreichen blockiert wurde ist von den
USA und von Großbritannien das sagt er
wirklich ja okay Nathalie Bennett über
den reden wir
und dieses Argument bringen sie in
letzter Zeit sehr häufig und sie sagen
immer aber man muss sich war der Krieg
hätte zu Ende sein können
mal die Mühe gemacht das genauer
anzusehen was Bennett wirklich gesagt
hat
in auf Twitter hat der folgendes gesagt
es ist fraglich ob ein Deal zustande
kommen würde damals gab ich dem Ganzen
eine Chance von etwa 50 Prozent
fifty-fifty das ist nicht wir sind ganz
in der Nähe eines Abkommens die
Amerikaner hielten die
Wahrscheinlichkeit für geringer es ist
schwer zu sagen wer Recht hatte woher
nehmen Sie also die Sicherheit zu sagen
das war ein greifbarer Nähe wörtlich hat
er das gesagt westblockted also was hat
er wirklich so gesagt noch mal 50%, er
sich selber nicht mehr sicher und heute
heute sagt er der ganz kurz muss noch
mal das ganze Bild zeichnen heute sagt
er selber Mann ist gar nicht sicher dass
ein solches Abkommen erstrebenswert war
damals dachte ich das war aber erst die
Zeit wird das zeigen ich kann für jeden
Ansatz Vor und Nachteile erkennen ja
aber das ist jetzt eine Bewertung er hat
damals versucht zu vermitteln und er hat
deutlich gemacht dass es nicht an
Russland und der Ukraine gescheitert ist
sondern an Großbritannien und den USA
und das ist auch eine Aussage er ist ja
auch nicht der einzige es gab danach
noch mal vorhandenen
Verhandlungen Istanbul der türkische
Außenminister sagt das gleiche
Leute erzählen auch der türkische
Außenminister sagt es hat am Ende daran
gelegen dass der Westen in interveniert
haben dass man damals keinen
Friedensschluss wollte sie sagen
Friedensschluss er redet nicht vom
Friedensschluss er redet von einem
Waffenstillstand
ist aber doch der erste Schritt zu einem
ich meine wir werden weiter wenn wir ein
Waffenstillstand hätten also ich würde
mir wünschen dass es jetzt eine
Initiative gäbe das zumindest erstmal
die Waffen viel zu klug als dass sie
nicht wüssten man kann sich doch an
diesem Punkt diese intellektuelle
Bequemlichkeit nicht leisten und nicht
präzise sprechen
präzise sprechen sie reden von einem
Friedensabkommen er redet von einem
Waffenstillstand ist eine völlig andere
Geschichte sie sagen die waren da ganz
schnell er sagt 50 Prozent das ist
Quatsch in dem Interview etwas anders
gesagt als sie das jetzt gerade
angestellt haben er hat gesagt dass ich
beide Seiten sehr stark aufeinander zu
bewegt haben das ist auf einem guten Weg
war und das dann die der Westen ist
blockiert haben lassen
gerade gar nicht darum ob das 50 oder
60% waren es war damals auf einem guten
Weg und es ist nicht an der ukrainischen
Führung geschaltet es ist aber auch
nicht an der russischen Führung
gescheiter das ist ein Argument dafür
ist wieder zu versuchen ich meine das
ist doch auch müßig jetzt darüber zu
reden was im Frühjahr war es zeigt ja
nur es geht Verhandlungen können
funktionieren es kann ja auch noch
andere Verhandlungen die auch
funktioniert haben über getreideabkommen
über Gefangenen Austausch und deswegen
brauchen wir jetzt wieder Verhandlungen
ungefähr zentrale Frage sie haben sich
eine harte Diskussion gewünscht deswegen
lassen Sie uns auch einfach hart und
ehrlich bin ich auch immer zu haben wir
reden jetzt seit vier fünf Minuten und
ich warte die ganze Zeit darauf
gesprochen ja dass das Wort Butcher
einmal fällt warum fällt den das in dem
Zusammenhang nicht ein das war doch der
Moment der alles verändert hat
waren vor Butcher als die anderen kamen
diese Bilder von Botschaft nein das
stimmt nicht die Gespräche von Bennet da
sein initiativer abgebrochen vor
Botschaft dann kamen die Verhandlungen
Istanbul und die Verhandlungen Istanbul
wurden tatsächlich abgebrochen mit
Verweis auf Gutschein das ist richtig es
gibt allerdings unterschiedliche
ob das der Grund war oder ob die Reise
von Johnson der Grund war aber selbst
wenn es so war dass Butcher der Grund
war also es tut mir leid
Kriegsverbrechen sind doch kein Grund
einen Krieg weiterzuführen
Kriegsverbrechen sind ein Grund mehr
einen Krieg zu beenden und zu versuchen
einen guten Stillstand zu erreichen und
in diesem Krieg werden furchtbare
Kriegsverbrechen begangen das sehen wir
doch jeden Tag
wieso sagen sie da werden
Kriegsverbrechen begangen
wenn ja nun sehr deutlich auch immer
wieder thematisiert und das ist leider
in allen Kriegen so also auch wenn die
übliche Darstellung sehr einseitig ist
es ist tatsächlich so dass in diesem
Krieg von beiden Seiten Kriegsverbrechen
begangen werden okay was denkt Frau
Melnik wenn Sie das hört
das ist für mich einfach eine
Wiederholung von der russischen
Propaganda und ich frage mich Frau
Wagenknecht sie als Politikerin sie
hatten die Möglichkeit die Ukraine
früher zu besuchen sie hatten 2014 von
Neo Faschisten Faschisten in der Ukraine
gesprochen von von irgendeinem Putsch
von Antisemiten die sozusagen an die
Macht jetzt gekommen sind das haben sie
alles damals gemacht und die frage mich
jeder kann von uns Fehler machen aber
sie hatten nie die Möglichkeit genutzt
einfach in die Ukraine zu reisen mit den
Menschen zu sprechen um sie zu verstehen
und da er frage ich Sie fragen
politische Verantwortung auch mit diesem
Manifest warum haben sie das bis heute
nicht gemacht und warum gibt es so viele
Möglichkeiten mit Menschen
dementsprechend mit der
Zivilgesellschaft die heute einfach
viele von denen nicht in der Lage sind
in der Ukraine zu bleiben und sie viele
von ihnen leben jetzt in Polen oder in
anderen europäischen Staaten versuchen
eigentlich die Perspektive der Ukraine
zu bringen und manchmal frage ich mich
sie haben gar kein Interesse sozusagen
mit ihnen zu sprechen und die Ukraine
Perspektive ich spreche natürlich auch
mit Ukrainerin ich bekomme
Mailänderin ich bekomme Mails von ihnen
ich habe mir hat vor kurzem eine junge
Ukrainerin die in Deutschland ist
geschrieben und die wahnsinnig sich
bedankt hat für unser Manifest und
gesagt hat sie hat Angst um ihre Familie
sie hat Angst um ihren Mann dir in der
Ukraine immer noch ist der nicht
ausreisen darf und die wird 600 km hat
sie mir gesagt nach Berlin kommen und um
an unserer Kundgebung am Samstag vom
Brandenburger Tor teilzunehmen also das
gibt es doch auch das ist auch die
Ukraine und ich meine dieser
politurismus wo man bewacht und
aufsichtig fährt
ja na das was jetzt so teilweise
stattfindet also ein Politiker bewacht
und beaufsichtigt fährt in ein Land
macht inszenierte Fotos und danach sagt
er ich weiß jetzt wie die Stimmung im
Land deswegen ich weiß nicht dahin weil
aus nicht glaube dass man so tatsächlich
ein Bild von dem von der Stimmung im
Land bekommt ich meine das ist ein Land
im Krieg man kann nicht mit allen Seiten
in diesem Land sprechen wenn man dorthin
reist und ich finde sie sollten jetzt
auch nicht die Debatte auf so einen
nebengleist ablenken es geht doch um die
große Frage
hat ihn eine sehr einfache Frage
gestellt warum fahren Sie nicht den
Ukraine machen sich mal ein Bild davon
ohne Fotografie nicht glaube dass wenn
man jetzt als Politiker in die Ukraine
fährt sich man sich wirklich ein Bild
machen kann und ich meine das kann gar
nicht zu fahren ist erst gar nicht zu
versuchen also an alle Länder zu denen
ich wo ich mich kundig mache wo ich
Dinge lese da muss ich nicht überall
hinfahren und wie gesagt diese Termine
die zurzeit stattfinden die Politiker
Reisen die in ein Land stattfinden
können in ein Land im Krieg das sind
keine reisen wo man wirklich ein Bild
bekommt und wenn sie jetzt zum Beispiel
kritisiert haben dass ich damals
angesprochen habe dass nach dem mal dann
Neofaschisten auch in der Regierung
waren ja dieses roboter-partei ist das
keine neofaschistische Partei gewesen
also das asof-bataillon die haben nehmen
faschistische Symbole die haben auch und
das muss man eben auch sagen es gab auch
schon Übergriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung auch schon vor dem
russischen einmal also das gehört doch
alles zur Wahrheit dazu ich finde es ist
einseitig einseitig über alles
und außerdem ist das alles kein Argument
gegen die Grundthese in unserem Papier
das jetzt endlich verhandelt werden muss
dass man diesen Krieg nur über
Verhandlungen beenden kann das ist doch
der Kern es geht ja gar nicht darum dass
wir jetzt nur sagen wir sollen keine
Waffen mehr liefern lassen
nicht nicht einfach sozusagen ohne Punkt
und Komma aber dann kommen wir irgendwie
nicht zu den habe ich würde wirklich
gerne zu den Argumenten einmal
durchdringen hat was interessant ist es
gab ja schon die Möglichkeit ab zwei 14
mal in die Ukraine zu fahren um zu sehen
was da passiert wenn sie sagen asafter
da waren ganz viele Neonazis drin oder
Nazis drin
ist eines linken ukrainischen
Journalisten gelesen der sagt das war
früher so aber das Asus Bataillon das da
jetzt in mariopol bis zum letzten
gekämpft hat das sind keine Faschisten
sagt dieser Mann der sich auskennt und
er sagt ich bin ein Linker ich habe
nichts zu tun 2014 kritisiert habe da
sind wir uns ja hoffentlich einig dass
das Faschisten waren und das ist eine
Versicherung
bitte
seit 2014 eigentlich hinter Ukraine
bereits schon zweimal
präsidentschaftsverein durchgeführt die
rechtsradikale in dem Trainer haben gar
keinen an Bedeutung gewonnen aber auch
die
parteivoroder konnte sich auch nicht
durchsetzen und insgesamt die
Rechtsradikalen haben insgesamt zwei
Prozent bei dem Parlamenten bleiben
damals in der Regierung aber ich frage
mich sie haben damals auch zum Beispiel
dafür eingesetzt sie haben soeben gesagt
es gab Übergriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung können Sie mir erklären
von welchen Übergriffen sprechen Sie da
von denen die der un-kommissar für
Menschenrechte Dokumentieren
von Folterung ist da die Rede von
Vergewaltigung von willkürlichen
Erschießungen das hat ja die UN selber
die haben ja die Beobachter da und das
hat haben die dokumentiert ich meine das
ist alles keine Rechtfertigung für
diesen Krieg damit mir nicht gleich
wieder was unterstellt wird
nein wieso das ist also wenn man ein
Verbrechen kritisiert hat man damit
nicht ein anderes Verbrechen relativiert
oder gerechtfertigt das möchte ich mal
hier festhalten ich finde dieses ist
richtig schön ich finde diesen Krieg ein
Verbrechen und deswegen möchte ich dass
dieser Krieg endet
ja das wollen sie alle sagen sie aber
sagen Sie mir mal irgendein
realistisches Konzept das der Westen zur
Zeit hat wie er den Krieg beenden will
mit Tanzen mit Kampfjets mit immer mehr
Waffen beendet man doch keinen Krieg
nochmal ganz kurz sagen das Konzept das
Putin gerade verfolgt mit immer mehr
Panzern mit immer mehr Kampfjets mit
immer mehr Raketen ist das das
Friedensangebot ist dass die Idee für
Verhandlungen
macht das genauso falsch wie wir also
das heißt doch nur zwei Züge rollen
aufeinander zu und es geht ewig weiter
sie fordern den deutschen Kanzler auf
diese Eskalation der Waffenlieferungen
zu stoppen ich denke aber warum
schreiben sie nicht dann werden die mir
Putin stoppe bitte diese Eskalation der
Waffenlieferung wäre das nicht der beste
sind und weil es hier darum geht wie die
deutsche Regierung handelt natürlich das
wäre es schön wenn Putin das stoppen
würde also wunderbar würde ich können
wir uns alle zurücklehnen und alles sehr
gut
realistisch nicht so sein das Putin wenn
man ihm nicht ein Kompromissangebot
macht sich aus der Ukraine komplett
zurückzieht und auch aus der Krippe das
wird nicht stattfinden
vorher aber Frau aufs janikova die
gerade wollte wenn Sie das Hören ist ja
total interessant sie sagten gerade ich
habe 20 Jahre
Propaganda gemacht diese narrative diese
Erzählungen ja wie man heute sagt
narrativ kommt in das bekannt vor
2014 habe ich das Gefühl
das Sarah Wagenknecht von Putin bezahlt
wird weil mit wem mit wem sollen sie
hier verhandeln wir wollen hier
verhandeln mit einem Kriegsverbrechen
der das ukrainische Volk ausrottet und
auch das eigene Erfolg ausrottet das was
jetzt in der Ukraine stattfindet ist
völkermordrainische
deswegen muss man diesen Menschen
Menschen
schicken und sie vertreten hier Putin
narrative und ich persönlich bin jetzt
in Lebensgefahr und versuche das zu
bekämpfen und sie forzieren seine
narrative und sagen wir müssen mit ihm
verhandeln wenn sagen dass jeder der
verhandeln will Putins Propaganda
verbreitet dann verbreitet offenbar also
auch der Papst gut ins Propaganda dann
verbreitet der brasilianische Präsident
Putins Propaganda dann verbreitet sogar
die RAND Corporation die ja gegründet
wurde um die US-Army zu beraten
putinpropaganda weil auch die RAND
Corporation hat vor kurzem eine Studie
veröffentlicht wo sie sehr deutlich
warnt dass beiden nicht seine bisherige
Strategie fortsetzen soll auf einen
langen abnutzungskrieg mit immer mehr
Waffenlieferung zu setzen weil auch die
randkorporation sagt das ist zu
gefährlich das kann in einen Atomkrieg
münden und sie fordert die beiden
Administration auf endlich den Weg auch
oder Initiativen zu ergreifen für
Verhandlungen ich meine das sagt die
randkooperation und ich werde hier
hingestellt wie immer der von Putin
bezahlt wird wenn ich sowas fordere also
das ist doch irre die deutsche Debatte
ist doch wirklich verrückt also wenn
Leute dieses Gefühl
immer wieder auch genauso
propagiert die sind die Reaktionen unser
Manifest sind aber witzig also natürlich
kann man für Verhandlungen plädieren
ohne in irgendeiner Weise den russischen
angriffskriegurt zu heißen und ich finde
das sollte man endlich mal zur Kenntnis
nehmen und ich vermisse wirklich wenn
sie sagen man darf mit Putin nicht
verhandeln wie soll dieser Krieg beendet
werden auch der oberste General der USA
sagt ganz klar am Ende wird das am
Verhandlungstisch beendet ohne
Verhandlung wird das nie beendet werden
also sollen noch jahrelang Menschen
sterben man ist doch keine Solidarität
mit der Ukraine wenn man Waffen liefert
genau abgemessen so dass es ein ewig
nutzungskrieg gibt jeden Tag sterben
hunderte Menschen die Ukraine wird immer
mehr zerstört das ist doch Wahnsinn
intensiver drüber
ich bin nur noch eine Sache was mir
wichtig ist wir kennen uns nicht
wirklich gut aber wir kennen uns von von
einigen Begegnungen hier will das nur
sagen ohne ohne dass ich das überprüfen
könnte ich bin mir ganz ganz ganz ganz
sicher dass hier jemand sitzt der sicher
nicht von Putin bezahlt wird deutlich
sagen lege ich meine Hand ins Feuer ohne
es genauer zu wissen aber mein Gefühl
sagt mir dass das so ist nur zu ihrer
Verteidigung sagen Kevin kühn hat wenn
Sie das Hören ich habe das eingangs
gesagt es wäre sehr leicht jemanden hier
hinzusetzen der einfach sagt das geht
gar nicht diese Position natürlich
müssen wir die Ukraine unterstützen
hätten Sie Verständnis dafür wenn man
sagt irgendwie wir machen das nicht mehr
und wie geht's denn dabei
Mitglied einer Partei zu sein die ja
auch eigentlich aus einer pazifistischen
Tradition kommt wenn man so will nicht
unbedingt okay
sie haben Recht aber der dennoch
sozusagen
darum geht
Waffenrüstung Bundeswehr mit dem Geld
könnte man was Besseres machen und die
einen sehr weiten Weg gehen musste von
ein paar Helmen ja bis hin zum Leo der
wie jetzt plötzlich liefern wie würden
sie es machen wie beurteilen Sie dieses
Manifest
naja nur weil jetzt dieser Krieg ist und
wir für uns zu dem Schluss kommen dass
diese Unterstützung auch auf
militärische Art neben einem anderen im
Moment
geboten ist und auch die bessere
Variante ist als alle anderen die auf
dem Tisch liegen heißt das ja nicht dass
wir nicht mehr Frieden für etwas
wünschenswertes halten würden das ist ja
das tun wir ja alle genau das ist ja das
verfängliche auch an dieser an dieser
Resolution oder wie man fest dass da
natürlich Begriffe genannt werden gegen
die ja erstmal jeder klar denken Mensch
nichts haben kann niemand hat was gegen
Verhandlungen aus um aus seiner
Konfliktsituation oder einem Krieg
herauszukommen denn das Sterben soll
aufhören das ist ein Satz dem jeder
sofort zustimmen würde
friesoy genau das ist alles richtig die
Frage ist ja nur weil ich sage es wäre
jetzt Verhandlung
sind noch keine Verhandlungen da und vor
allem bleiben sie finde ich die Antwort
schuldig worüber mit welchem Ziel soll
den verhandelt werden wir reden jetzt
ganz viel über unsere Ziele also wir
wollen nicht mehr dass das ist das hält
uns auf das bringt alles durcheinander
das steigert eine atomare Gefahr auf der
russischen Seite ist sorgt für Flucht
und migrationsbewegung aber was ist denn
das Ziel für die die überfallen worden
sind eigentlich ja ich glaube auch dafür
muss man jetzt nicht zwingen vor Ort
gewesen sein aber die Frage muss ja im
Mittelpunkt stehen was sind denn
Konditionen für diejenigen die aus der
Situation des unterdrückten heraus ein
Frieden schließen sollen was sind denn
die Konditionen damit die das tun und
damit die da drin auch Frieden finden
noch persönlich Frieden finden nämlich
einen der nachhaltig ist und gerecht ist
bei dem man nicht ein paar Jahre später
wieder die Erfahrung macht das wieder
wie von so einer Salami eine Scheibe vom
eigenen Land abgeschnitten wird das ist
ja jetzt die sich wiederholende
Erfahrung die Menschen in der Ukraine
seit 2015 gemacht haben so und deswegen
stelle ich die Frage auch Ihnen Frau
Wagenknecht worüber soll eigentlich
genau verhandelt werden und finden Sie
es nicht bemerkenswert dass sie
überhaupt nur hier sitzen und die
Forderungen nach einer Verhandlung
stellen können weil es die Ukraine auch
wegen der Waffenlieferung noch gibt
hätte niemand Waffen geliefert seit
Beginn dieses Krieges könnten wir heute
nicht mehr darüber sprechen dass die
Ukraine mit Russland unter Zuhilfenahme
von anderen Staaten wem auch immer etwas
verhandeln könnte es gäbe eine es gäbe
die Ukraine völkerrechtlich noch aber
sie wäre besetzt und zwar wahrscheinlich
auf dem gesamten Staatsgebiet die
Regierung wäre gemorchelt oder hätte ins
Ausland fliegen müssen also sie müssen
doch anerkennen dass sie überhaupt nur
den Weg zu einer Verhandlung finden
kann bisher also ich habe das im
Frühjahr anders wahrgenommen es gab
früher Friedensgespräche und ich hätte
mir gewünscht dass der Westen die aus
vollem Herzen unterstützt hätte und es
gab ja verschiedene Berichte darüber wie
damals ein Rahmen des Abkommens aussah
ein Schlüssel war natürlich und das ist
ja auch der Kern des Krieges es geht in
diesem Krieg primär nicht um Territorien
es geht um mögliche Militärbasis und
raketenstützpunkte das heißt es geht
darum das hat Russland auch vor dem
Krieg immer ganz deutlich gesagt wo die
Menschen in der Ukraine von denen sie
verlangen ein Frieden zu schließen geht
es natürlich sie haben jetzt schon sehr
viel geredet eigentlich aber ich möchte
das jetzt doch mal deutlich machen also
vorhin erfährst ist ja eine
amerikanische Zeitschrift die dem
Außenministerium nahe steht dort war
eine Rahmen also das war noch nicht
fertig damit sie nicht gleich wieder
kommen also es war noch nicht
unterschriftzeichen aber der Rahmen
eines Abkommens wurde in Form erfährst
dargestellt und der bestand darin dass
die Ukraine sich verpflichtet in Zukunft
auf Neutralität weil die russische
Führung eben immer wieder deutlich
gemacht ihr Kernanliegen ist dass die
Ukraine nicht zu einem militärischen
Vorposten der Vereinigten Staaten wird
mit Militärstützpunkten möglicherweise
Raketen waren das war immer der Kern die
alte Geschichte
begonnen das ist in der alte
nato-geschichte die Sie gerade erzählen
die ist neu und im Frühjahr war so also
nochmal erfahren
also ich meine die USA würde genauso
handeln wenn es darum ginge dass China
in Mexiko geht ob Sie Verständnis dafür
haben ich verstehe dass sie nicht
Reichweite also Raketen stationiert
haben wollen die in fünf Minuten
Moskauer erreichen das verstehe ich so
ansonsten kann man immer ein anderes
Land nein das ist keine Rechtfertigung
für den Krieg aber das ist eine Ursache
des Konflikts und im früher gab es wie
gesagt einen Rahmen für ein mögliches
Abkommen der das angeblich nach vorne
erfährst beinhalte die Ukraine
verpflichtet sich der Neutralität
bekommt allerdings Sicherheitsgarantien
und Russland zieht sich hinter die
Linien des 24 Februar zurück Leute noch
mal hinbekommen
damals dieses Abkommen unbedingt zu
versuchen zu verhandeln und es nicht zu
blockieren dann hätte man auch keine
Waffen mehr nicht
noch die anderen bitte sprechen lassen
will nur noch einmal sagen es wird
dadurch nicht wahrer das ist einfach die
ganze Zeit wiederholen es gab dieses
Momentum sie silencia hat sogar gesagt
wir streben keine NATO-Mitgliedschaft an
das hat auch öffentlich gesagt hat er
sich davon und dann Kambodscha was macht
man denn als Präsident eines Landes wenn
man einer Bevölkerung solche Bilder
zumuten muss du kannst dich doch nicht
als Politiker vorne hinstellen und sagen
okay ist in Ordnung
da werden Frauen vergewaltigt nein
Russen vergewaltigen Frauen und zwar
ukrainische Frauen das sie sagen dass
alles nie deutlich weil es natürlich im
Wagen sehr viel besser zu argumentieren
ist
zu dem Thema
wirklich wir haben grundlegend
Unterschiede mit ihnen aber ich wollte
auch darauf hinweisen nicht die Nase und
die USA sind das Problem wäre das der
Fall gewesen dann hätte Russland keine
Listen
zu Ermordung von CDs Zivilisten
geschaffen dann hätte Russland nicht
Deportation von ukrainischen Kindern
veranstaltet und organisieren dann
hätten wir in der Ukraine keine
filtrationslager gehabt und die
ukrainischen Bücher hätte man nicht
verbrannt die Nato hat damit nichts zu
tun das ist das was eigentlich Pünktchen
seit 2014 erzählt die NATO steht
vielleicht in so einem Masse eine
Bedrohung für Putin da in dem eigentlich
das ist die einzige Russland weiß und
Putin weiß wenn wenn die Ukraine die
Mitgliedschaft der NATO bekommt und
Mitgliedschaft in der Europäischen Union
dann wird diese sozusagen für immer und
ewig entfalten und sich von Russland
ablösen in dem Fall ist die NATO
sozusagen die Bedrohung aber nichts
anderes und ich frage mich woher warum
ignorieren Sie all diese Verbrechen
sozusagen
darf ich auch sprechen
und der nächste Moment ich möchte jetzt
zurück zu zu ihrem Manifest eigentlich
was mich in der ganzen Debatte auch
wundern sie haben kein einziges Mal von
vom Wort oder das Wort Gerechtigkeit in
den Mund genommen und sie sprechen nicht
über diese Menschen was machen wir mit
diesen Menschenrechtsverbrechen das
heißt wir setzen uns an den
Verhandlungstisch verhandeln mit Pudding
und er sagt dann und wir verzeihen ihn
im all diese Menschenrechtsverbrechen
was sie noch machen mit diesem Manifest
sie schaffen
Illusionen dass wenn die Verhandlungen
stattfinden werden dann haben wir gar
keine Konflikt mehr wenn sie wirklich
das Gute dann sagen würde so liebe
Ukraine wir nehmen jetzt diese
Territorien und dann kannst du dich
jetzt demokratischen entwickeln oder was
ja was ist ihre Lösung dieses meine
Lösung ist dass die Ukraine keine
Zugeständnisse macht meine wird nein
nein nein nein nein meine Oma hat zehn
Seminare in polark verbracht mein Opa 25
und ich hätte nie gedacht dass meine
Generation auch heute für die
Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine einsetzen
wird ja und einsetzen muss und ich hätte
mir gedacht dass diese wenn wir über
dass wir nicht über Zugeständnisse von
der ukrainischen Seite die ganze Zeit
sprechen würden ich sehe zum Beispiel
wenn wir über Verhandlungen sprechen ich
sehe nicht dann was kann die Husten
sozusagen dann abliefern
das so spannend ist ihre Großeltern
waren im Gulag beide sehr lange warum
sie waren einfach für die Ukrainisch für
die Ukraine sie kamen aus dem weißen
Dunkeln wie viele und damals ich glaube
das ist ein großer Unterschied
dass man man kennt sehr viele Verbrechen
aus dem zweiten weil Krieg aber
irgendwie diesen grauen Grausamkeiten
die Stalin sozusagen gebracht hat kennt
man nicht und das können wir uns
sozusagen das gar nicht vorstellen ja
und das systematische aushungern von
Ukraine wenn wir über Russland sprechen
leider das ist das alles begann nicht
mit 2014 sondern wir haben ganz andere
Geschichte zu Russland und wir wissen
auch wozu Russland fähig ist ist das uns
das was wir
häufig falsch verstehen deswegen war er
fand ich von so ein interessante Frage
ob Frau Wagen gleich mal in der Ukraine
war ich war da auch nie ich würde gerne
mal hinreisen um weil ich schon daran
glaube dass man ein Land und eine Kultur
und auch das was Motive sind für
Menschen das zu tun was sie tun deutlich
besser versteht wenn man sich vor Ort
umhört und mit Menschen spricht das gar
keine Frage was verstehen wir falsch an
diesem Verhältnis zwischen Russland und
der Ukraine wir haben sehr lange die
Ukraine durch die russische Brille
betrachtet wir haben die Ukraine nicht
alles
unabhängigen Akteur sozusagen
wahrgenommen und was ich jetzt in der
Debatte sozusagen nicht tolerieren kann
das waren die Ukraine irgendwie als
Marionette von den USA darstellen möchte
dass das ist das diese der starke
Anti-Amerikanismus das in Deutschland
auch da ist das muss man auch schon
sagen weil zum Beispiel die
Amerikanismus haben wir in der Ukraine
nicht und das
ja diese Eigenständigkeit und Ukraine
leider
[Musik]
der Begriff eine amerikanische
Marionette und sie sagten oder habe ich
sie falsch interpretiert
eine amerikanische Marionette in ihren
Augen ich weiß nicht wie groß die
Handlungsspielräume von selensky aktuell
sind das sage ich ehrlich ich meine ist
völlig abhängig davon dass der Westen
ihm weiter Waffen liefert
amerikanischen Marionette entschuldigung
ich habe den Begriff ja auch nicht
verwandt aber ich würde nicht denken
dass das Lenski zur Zeit Dinge tun kann
die nicht mit dem besten abgestimmt sind
das kann er zurzeit Objektiv nicht und
deswegen ist er natürlich in der
Situation nicht zu bereinigen und nicht
unabhängig außerdem sollte man nicht
ganz vergessen ich meine natürlich haben
die USA sich massiv in die ukrainischen
Belange eingemischt also Viktoria Julian
die ja heute viel zu Außenministerin ist
hat selbst zugegeben dass man 5
Milliarden Dollar investiert hat um eine
pro amerikanische und anti russische
Regierung an die Macht zu bringen das
war ja der Umsturz ist meine Daten also
die Ursache hat natürlich schon in der
Ukraine sich sehr sehr sehr stark auch
engagiert auch sehr bewusst engagiert
das hat nicht zur Befriedung der
Situation beigetragen dass das
Verhältnis entschuldigen
2014 ist
bei ihnen stattgefunden oder nicht
selbstverständlich hat das stattgefunden
das war völkerrechtswidrig aber es
wardrig natürlich völliger
keiner was ja also die Schwarzmeerflotte
war schon dort und auch das hatte
natürlich mit den Entwicklungen in der
Ukraine zu tun ich würde ihn doch völlig
zugestehen dass das Verhältnis zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine oder auch die
Verhältnisse in der Ukraine zwischen dem
russischen sprachigen und dem
ukrainischen Teil dass die
spannungsgeladen sind das ist ja
offensichtlich aber die Frage ist solche
Spannungen führen oder versucht man
diese Spannungen zu abzubauen
damals nachdem mal da an sie haben weil
wir gerade dieses diesen Tag 24 Februar
reden wir gerade so viel sie im
Fernsehen im deutschen Fernsehen bei
Kollegin Anne Will gesessen und sagten
ich habe das Gefühl kurz vor dem einen
Marsch der Westen versucht wirklich die
Amerikaner versuchen wirklich diesen
Einmarsch herbeizureden sie hatten
damals die USA hatte damals einen Termin
genannt waren die Russen einmarschieren
der war nicht da war kein Einmarsch und
sehr viele haben ich auch nicht damit
gerechnet das ist tatsächlich zu diesem
Krieg kommt ich habe allerdings in der
gleichen Sendung und das möchte ich auch
noch mal betonen gewarnt dass
möglicherweise dieser Konflikt
militärisch eskaliert weil die Russen
sichtlich das konnte man ja aus der
ganzen Rhetorik entnehmen entschlossen
waren und jeden Preis zu verhindern dass
die Ukraine immer mehr in die
militärischen Strukturen in der Nase
integriert werden konnten das
nachvollziehen oder versuchen Sie mir
doch jetzt nicht immer in den Mund zu
legen dass ich irgendetwas irgendein
Verständnis für diesen Krieg habe ich
lehne Kriege grundsätzlich ab jede Art
von Krieg und ich meine
Länder ihre Interessen mit militärischen
Mitteln versuchen durchzusetzen das
finde ich zutiefst verurteilenswert aber
mit verurteilen beenden wir eben diesen
Krieg nicht und deswegen finde ich es
ist jetzt an der Zeit dass wir nicht nur
verurteilen sondern etwas dafür tun
diesen Krieg zu beenden und mir fehlen
bei denen die uns kritisieren die sagen
mit Verhandlungen geht's nicht fehlen
die Argumente wie es denn anders gehen
soll also es tut mir leid ich sehe sie
nicht es ist der Weg in immer mehr
Eskalation immer mehr Waffen immer mehr
Krieg und ich sehe nicht wie das auf
diese Weise beendet wird im Gegenteil
ich fürchte dass uns das irgendwann
immer mehr reinziehen ja die Frage haben
sie zwischendurch schon aufgeworfen und
die ist ja auch total berechtigt was
sind denn eigentlich die anderen
Vorschläge und die Sache ist aus meiner
Sicht so die meisten kommen gar nicht zu
einem großartig anderen Ergebnis als sie
die meisten würden die Frage beantworten
dass dieser Krieg wohl über
Verhandlungen am Ende auch erledigt
werden muss man kann ja historisch
gucken wie Enden Krieger kann so enden
wie Deutschland zwei Weltkriege beendet
hat mit einer absoluten militärischen
Niederlage und Kapitulation aus Kosten
von Millionen Zivilisten und Soldaten
und Soldaten das kann niemand wollen
deswegen
kenne ich auch kaum jemanden der das
jetzt als Lösung für diesen Krieg Preis
gibt also dass das am Ende was mit
Verhandlungen und mit dem Überwinden von
auch ideologischen Grenzen an zu tun
haben wird das ist relativ naheliegend
woran finde ich ihre Argumentation krank
denn im Manifest wie auch hier in der
Sendung ist dass wir wir haben jetzt
über alles Mögliche gesprochen werden
über Nacht der Liebe Bennet gesprochen
wir haben über Folgen Vers gesprochen
wir haben über NATO Stützpunkte
gesprochen über Kapazitäten gesprochen
über die Europäische Union über
Deutschland über das Silber über die
Chinesen über alles haben wir gesprochen
nur sie blenden den entscheidenden
Faktor aus und das ehrlicherweise auch
aus Gründen das entscheidende Puzzleteil
nehmen sie aus dem Spiel raus was sie
eigentlich für eine Lösung brauchen und
das ist die Ukraine selbst sie sprechen
höchstens pflichtschuldig auch in dieser
in diesem Manifest über die Ukraine sie
machen so nehme ich das war die Ukraine
von einem Subjekt von einem handelnden
Subjekt
Objekt zu einem Spielstein der in der
internationalen Politik hin und
hergeschoben wird ich bin kein
Esoteriker ich weiß dass es auch im
machtpolitische Fragen und Interessen
und so weiter geht das muss am Ende
alles eine Rolle spielen aber sie reden
über mögliche Lösungen und Vereinbarung
die irgendwo wer aufgeschrieben hat ohne
einmal zu hinterfragen ob eigentlich die
Ukraine damit einverstanden gewesen wäre
auf der demokratisch gewählte Präsident
der Ukraine vor sein Volk mit den
Bildern von treten kann und sagen kann
ich empfehle uns als Nation das als
Lösung und ich glaube dass darin ein
nachhaltiger gerechter Frieden liegt bei
dem wir nicht in fünf Jahren wieder uns
an der Front mit den Russen treffen
müssen diesen Faktor blenden Sie einfach
aus und deswegen ist mit der Forderung
es soll verhandelt werden und
irgendwelche zusammen sein das
entscheidende nicht beantworten auch
eine Verantwortung hat wir munitionieren
diesen Krieg selenski hat aktuell die
Position wie gesagt früher hat er eine
andere also da haben sich andere über
seinen Kopf weggesetzten früher
hr-kompromissbereit jetzt hat lenzige
die Position er hat ja in Dekret
erlassen dass erst nach der
Rückeroberung der Krim überhaupt
Verhandlungen möglich sind also hat
Verhandlungen verboten bis die Creme
zurückerobert wird ich halte das für
eine verantwortungslose Position sage
ich ganz ehrlich
verantwortungslose Position ja und ich
finde dass der Westen sich das nicht so
eigen machen darf weil natürlich wir
inzwischen ein Teil in gewisser Weise ja
ein Teil dieses Krieges sind und das
heißt wir sind was sind wir
völkerrechtlich nicht
zum Glück Kriegspartei im Sinne dessen
dass unsere Soldaten involviert sind
diese Richtung zurückgewiesen die
Flugzeuge Truppen das muss man ja auch
für die Menschen in Deutschland sprechen
dass wir Teil dieses Krieges sind Partei
sind gefühlt das ist das was wenn wir in
der Größenordnung wie wir es jetzt tun
Waffen liefern Panzer liefern womöglich
morgen Kampfjets liefern dann sind wir
doch Teil dieses doch tatsächlich
deswegen hat ja Scholz aus gutem Grund
gezögert und ich meine kümmert ich habe
sie ja in mehreren Fernsehtalkshows
gesehen wo sie damals meines Erachtens
mit guten Argumenten begründet haben
warum Scholz die Kampfpanzer nicht
liefert so jetzt hat er sie aber
freigegeben und all die Argumente von
damals sind aber eigentlich immer noch
richtig also unter anderem haben sie ja
gesagt da müssten mindestens alle
anderen auch liefern aber amerikanisch
sind im nächsten Jahr auch die
europäischen Verbündeten haben sich alle
weggeduckt sie haben Deutschland
wirklich reingelegt auch in der
panzerfrage wir stehen verdammt allein
da und ist das ist doch eine unkluge
Politik also wir sind schon auch für uns
mitverantwortlich aber ich verweigere
auch die These das ist eine Solidarität
mit der Ukraine ist eine langen
abnutzungs Musik mit zigtausenden Toten
mit Waffen zu beliefern das ist doch
keine Solidarität das ist doch wirklich
das ist doch zynisch also zu sagen wir
liefern immer Waffen wir gucken dass die
Ukraine nicht zu stark wird nein
verhandeln ist nicht kapitulieren